dans la recherche médicale contre le cancer
est l'invention du réfrigérateur.
(Rires)
Ouais, je sais.
On ne s'en sort pas bien.
Je ne veux pas minimiser le progrès
et tout ce qui a été fait comme recherches sur le cancer.
Plus de cinquante années de bonne recherche sur le cancer
ont permis de découvrir des choses majeures sur le cancer.
Cela dit,
il y a encore énormément de travail à accomplir.
Je peux soutenir que la raison principale de notre échec
est que nous nous battons à l'aveuglette.
C'est là que l'imagerie médicale entre en jeu,
que mon travail entre en jeu.
Pour vous donner une idée de la meilleure imagerie médicale
qui est offerte aux patients de cancer du cerveau
et à tous les patients de cancer,
regardez ce TEP.
Voilà.
Ceci est un TEP/TDM
et ce que vous y voyez
est que le TDM vous montrera où sont les os
et le TEP vous montrera où sont les tumeurs.
Ce que vous pouvez voir ici
est en gros une molécule de sucre
qui a été ajoutée, une balise
qui, nous dit, à nous à l'extérieur du corps :
« Je suis là. »
Ces molécules de sucre sont injectées par milliards dans le patient
et elles parcourent le corps
à la recherche de cellules voulant du sucre.
Vous voyez par exemple que le cœur s'éclaire ici
car le cœur a besoin de beaucoup de sucre.
La vessie aussi s'éclaire
car la vessie est ce qui élimine
le sucre de notre corps.
Quand vous voyez d'autres points,
ce sont des tumeurs.
C'est une technologie extraordinaire.
Pour la première fois, elle nous permet de voir l'intérieur du corps
sans avoir à prélever chacune des cellules
pour les observer au microscope,
de façon non invasive, elle permet de regarder l'intérieur du corps
et voir si le cancer a métastasé,
et où.
Les TEP ici montrent clairement
où sont les tumeurs.
Aussi miraculeux que cela paraisse,
malheureusement, ce n'est pas si génial.
Vous voyez ces petits points ici.
Selon vous, de combien de cellules cancéreuses sont composées les tumeurs ?
Environ 100 millions de cellules cancéreuses.
Je vais m'assurer que vous perceviez bien cela.
Chacun de ces points
que vous voyez sur l'image
doit être composé d'au moins 100 millions de cellules cancéreuses
afin d'être détecté.
Si cela vous semble être un nombre important,
c'est le cas.
C'est un nombre incroyablement grand
car nous avons besoin, afin de détecter quelque chose assez tôt
pour pouvoir agir, faire quelque chose de significatif,
nous devons détecter les tumeurs qui font un millier de cellules
et, idéalement, seulement quelques cellules.
Nous en sommes clairement loin.
Nous allons faire une petite expérience.
Je vais vous demander à tous de jouer et d'imaginer
que vous êtes neurochirurgien.
Vous êtes dans la salle d'opération,
il y a un patient devant vous
et votre tâche est de vous assurer que la tumeur est enlevée.
Vous regardez le patient,
la peau et le crâne ont déjà été enlevés,
vous regardez le cerveau.
Tout ce que vous savez de ce patient
est qu'il a une tumeur de la taille d'une balle de golf
dans le lobe frontal droit de son cerveau.
C'est à peu près tout.
Vous regardez et, malheureusement, tout se ressemble
car le tissu cérébral cancéreux et le tissu cérébral sain
ont exactement le même aspect.
Vous utilisez votre pouce,
vous appuyez un peu sur le cerveau
car les tumeurs sont un peu plus dures, rigides
et donc vous y allez, vous faites un peu comme cela,
la tumeur semble être juste ici.
Puis vous sortez votre scalpel et retirez la tumeur,
morceau par morceau.
En extrayant la tumeur,
arrive un point où vous pensez :
« J'ai fini, j'ai tout extrait. »
A ce point-là, si --
jusqu'ici tout semblait assez fou -
vous allez devoir prendre la décision la plus difficile de votre vie.
Car vous devez décider
si vous devriez vous arrêter, laisser le patient partir,
risquer qu'il reste des cellules cancéreuses
que vous n'avez pas vues,
ou vous prenez une marge supplémentaire,
en général 3 cm autour de la tumeur,
pour vous assurer d'avoir tout enlevé.
Ce n'est pas un choix facile
et, malheureusement, c'est la décision
que les neurochirurgiens doivent faire chaque jour
avec leurs patients.
Je me souviens avoir parlé à des amis au labo et avoir dit :
« Il doit y avoir une meilleure façon de faire. »
Pas comme vous dites à un ami qu'il doit y avoir une meilleure solution.
Il devait y avoir une meilleure solution.
C'est simplement incroyable.
On est reparti du début.
Souvenez-vous de ces TEP dont je vous ai parlé, avec le sucre.
Au lieu d'utiliser des molécules de sucre,
nous avons pensé utiliser de petites particules d'or
en les programmant chimiquement.
Les programmer pour chercher les cellules cancéreuses.
Ensuite, nous injecterons ces particules d'or
par milliards chez les patients,
elles parcourront le corps
et, comme des agents secrets,
iront voir chaque cellule de notre corps,
frapperont à la porte,
et demanderont si elle est cancéreuse ou saine.
Si elle est saine, on continue.
Si elle est cancéreuse, la particule reste, brille
et nous dit : « Regardez-moi, je suis là. »
On pourrait les voir grâce à des caméras
inventées au labo.
Si vous voyons cela, nous pouvons guider les neurochirurgiens
pour qu'ils enlèvent la tumeur sans toucher au cerveau sain.
Nous avons testé cela, cela fonctionne bien.
Je vais vous montrer un exemple.
Vous voyez ici
une image du cerveau d'une souris.
Nous avons implanté une tumeur dans le cerveau de cette souris.
Cette tumeur grossit,
nous avons demandé à un docteur
d'opérer la souris comme si c'était un patient
et d'enlever la tumeur, morceau par morceau.
Alors qu'il fait cela,
nous prenons des photos pour voir où sont les particules d'or.
Pour commencer,
nous injectons les particules d'or dans la souris,
ce que nous allons voir ici tout à gauche,
l'image en bas,
c'est l'image qui montre où sont les particules d'or.
Ce qui est bien, c'est que les particules d'or
sont arrivées dans la tumeur,
elles brillent et nous disent : « Nous sommes là. La tumeur est là. »
Nous pouvons voir la tumeur
mais nous ne la montrons pas encore au docteur.
Nous demandons au docteur d'enlever la tumeur,
vous verrez qu'il n'a enlevé que le premier quart de la tumeur
qui a maintenant disparu.
Le docteur a ensuite enlevé le deuxième, le troisième
et il semble qu'il ait tout enlevé.
A ce point-là, le docteur nous dit :
« J'ai fini. Que voulez-vous que je fasse ?
Devrais-je laisser cela ainsi
ou devrais-je prendre une marge supplémentaire ? »
On lui a dit d'attendre.
On lui a dit : « Vous avez oublié ces deux endroits,
plutôt que de prendre des marges autour,
enlevez seulement ces petites zones.
Enlevez-les puis on regardera à nouveau. »
Le docteur les a enlevées et voilà,
le cancer a complètement disparu.
Ce qui est important
n'est pas juste que le cancer ait complètement disparu
du cerveau de cette personne
ou de cette souris.
Le plus important
est que nous n'avons pas eu à enlever trop de cerveau sain
au cours du processus.
Nous pouvons imaginer un monde
où les docteurs et chirurgiens, en enlevant les tumeurs,
savent quoi enlever
et n'ont plus besoin d'utiliser leur pouce.
Voici pourquoi il est très important d'enlever ces restes de tumeur.
Ces restes de tumeur, même si ce ne sont que quelques cellules,
vont grossir et reformer la tumeur,
la tumeur va revenir.
La raison pour laquelle 80% à 90%
des chirurgies du cerveau finissent par échouer
est à cause de ces petites marges supplémentaires laissées,
ces petits restes de tumeurs laissés derrière.
Cela est très bien,
mais ce que je veux partager avec vous est ma vision de la direction prise.
Dans mon labo à Stanford,
mes étudiants et moi nous demandons ce sur quoi nous devrions travailler.
Je pense que l'imagerie médicale se dirige vers
la capacité à regarder l'intérieur du corps humain
et à voir toutes ces cellules séparément.
Cette capacité nous permettrait
de détecter des tumeurs bien, bien plus tôt,
avant d'avoir 100 millions de cellules, afin de pouvoir agir.
La capacité de voir toutes ces cellules nous permettrait
de poser des questions pointues.
Au labo, nous arrivons au point
où nous pouvons poser
de vraies questions aux cellules cancéreuses,
par exemple, savoir si elles répondent au traitement qui leur est donné.
Si elles ne répondent pas, nous pourrons l'arrêter immédiatement,
après quelques jours et non trois mois.
Pour des patients comme Ehud
qui prennent des médicaments de chimiothérapie très mauvais,
pour qu'ils ne souffrent pas
de ces épouvantables effets secondaires des médicaments
alors que ces médicaments ne les aident même pas.
Pour être franc,
nous sommes encore loin de gagner la guerre contre le cancer,
je suis juste réaliste.
Mais au moins j'ai espoir
que nous devrions pouvoir nous battre
avec de meilleures techniques d'imagerie
afin de ne pas le faire à l'aveuglette.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)